this video is sponsored by Squarespace
stick around until the end of the video
to find out
more hey there guys so it turns out my
last full follow along functional
workout was really popular lots of
people asked for more so here you go one
of the most common requests was from a
similar workout that you could do at
home my last one included sprinting
lizard crawling tree branches so this is
one you can do from the comfort of your
living room and still get a lot of the
same benefits
this has created a bit of a challenge
when it comes to the filming my home is
fairly small covered in kids toys and
generally not that cinematic or
conducive to filming with my preferred
tighter lenses so apologies if some of
the shots are a little more Rough Around
the Edges than my other
content I also want to show that this
can be done with zero equipment this is
a workout that everyone can build up to
so that means we're going to need to get
creative with training particularly when
it comes to the lats and the biceps but
you'll see that it is possible I'll also
be talking through the video again
hopefully you'll learn a couple of
things and I can explain my reasoning
with the exercise selection Etc these
types of videos offer a great
opportunity to demonstrate just how to
apply the various Concepts and exercises
I've discussed into an actual training
plan right now I'm warming up with some
100 UPS AKA high knees made a whole
video on these I'm going to do two sets
of one minute each the first one I'm
starting fairly gentle the second one
I'm bringing these up a bit higher going
a bit
harder the 100 up is a fantastic
exercise for building the hip flexors
and for building hip stability it's also
great for ankle stiffness just like jump
rope and it'll build your carves a
little
bit of course we're using it mainly here
for its cardio benefits and to get the
blood flowing around the body warming us
up nicely the 100 up was developed by
Walter George a runner as a way for him
to train running in his spare time
apparently this technique allowed him to
become one of the most decorated Runners
of his time it's a great alternative to
something like jump rope because you can
do it in this small space with no
worries about smashing everything off of
your TV stand just do go easy on your
ankles as you get a bit faster this is a
warm-up and the main job is to get blood
flowing to the joints and around your
body so don't Hammer your toes into the
ground and end up hurting your ankles I
do this a lot but if you don't you can
start much slower or even do a kind of
power walk on the spot which is known as
the 100 up Miner I'm resting for just 30
seconds between
[Music]
rounds now onto our active stretches to
improve Mobility for the impending
workout as I've said before stretching
preworkout isn't always the best if
you're using passive stretches there is
some evidence suggest that this can
increase your injury risk however a this
is blown massively out of proportion and
and B if we're using more controlled
active Mobility that is getting into
those positions and using our strength
then we don't have those same
risks so first up is the Deep squat for
1 minute this is an absolute staple and
something everyone should be working
towards try and keep your heels flat on
the floor weight distributed evenly over
your feet and your back as straight as
possible throughout all these movements
make sure to keep breathing in a calm
manner this will not only help you to
release unwanted tension and to thereby
get more from the mobility training but
it will also help you to practice
breathing more calmly as you exert
yourself something that can really help
to improve your performance in other
movements next we're moving on to 1
minute of deep lunges 30 seconds on each
side there's no need to rest between
these here you're trying to get a
stretch on the hip flexors predominantly
again get into that furthest position
then use your strength and control to
move deeper and then back out and move
around the area
undulating if you guys are familiar with
the way I do Mobility work you know I'm
going to be getting near to the end
range and then moving gently around in
that position not just holding one
position this isn't as much about
building strength and control in these
weaker positions as it is anything else
once you do that your body will relax to
allow you to move more freely so
ostensibly this is the warm-up
practicing these Mobility moves at the
start of our training is getting the
blood flow into those areas and it's
giving us a greater range of motion for
when we actually perform the working
sets later on we shouldn't just think of
it like that this is part of the workout
this isn't spinning our Wheels it's
helping us to move better reducing pain
and stiffness working on our appropri
setion ultimately making us stronger
especially at those end ranges working
out doesn't just mean building muscle
that's only part of the
story
next we're doing one minute of CAC
squats 30 seconds for each side these
are a great movement for getting us into
the frontal plane moving side to side
they stretch and strengthen the hips as
well as the hamstrings a quick tip is
that you can choose to Target the
hamstrings more or the hips more by
turning the extended foot to point up or
to point forwards respectively so if you
rest on your heel and point the toes up
that will train your hamstrings more if
you point the toes forwards and keep
your foot flat on the floor that will
Traen the hip abductors more
[Music]
you can also choose to focus more on
that leg or to put your back heel down
flatter on the floor training your ankle
Mobility a little bit there as
well go easy on this one as it's easy to
hurt yourself if you go too deep too
soon our next Mobility move is the crab
reach 30 seconds on each side get into
crab position so that your hands are
stacked under your shoulders and feet
under your knees then raise your crotch
to the heavens and try and create as
flat torso as possible then take one
hand and reach across and behind you
over your head follow your hand with
your eyes as you do this actually makes
a big
[Music]
difference are you enjoying this format
guys if so I can do more like this in
future let me know what you'd like to
see some ideas I've had include a home
workout including common gym equipment
like dumbbells Etc because I know most
of you have dumbbells and we can do
something a little bit more
comprehensive that
[Music]
way a follow along functional gym
workout is another option where you know
where you follow me around the gym and
I'll show you how I use the equipment
there in a more functional structured
workout and maybe even they follow along
Train like Batman workout using a whole
bunch of equipment like sandbags and
things let me know in the comments which
of those you like the sounds of and if
that's something you'd like to see more
of in
[Music]
future I made a whole video on crabs if
you want more info this is a great way
to develop some core stability while
also building shoulder mobility and
thoracic spine Mobility it's also our
first movement in the rotational plane
we're not even finished with the warmup
yet and we've already covered all three
planes not
bad finally it's doorway openers for 45
seconds
each these serve to stretch open the
shoulders nicely your job is to really
feel this in the right places
specifically that means the lats and the
[Music]
pecs your job then is to find the
position where you really feel that
stretch and then try moving around that
area you can also push into the door
frame more from that position or you can
try lifting your arm gently off these
are called
liftoffs to do this you should be moving
into a greater information than you're
normally capable of and this should be
using your strength to accomplish
that these shoulder openers have been
working really well for me helping me to
get a much straighter handstand for
example for the longest time I wasn't
getting much benefit from my shoulder
Mobility work but by really focusing on
which antagonists I'm meant to be
targeting I've seen a rapid Improvement
other options include doing dislocates
with a stick of some sort or using a
sofa to do similar openers while on your
knees while I think there's been an
overreaction to the findings that
passive stretches before my warm-up can
be harmful I would still advise a little
Caution here this is the closest to a
passive stretch out of these moves so
just be sure not to push too far and to
keep an element of strength
throughout now next up are some
activation exercises es these are
exercises that teach you the right
movement patterns and that get you
moving correctly for the following
workout we're starting with the
one-legged bodyweight good morning eight
repetitions on each side for just one
set the idea is to hinge at the hips on
one leg while reaching fors with the
same hand you're also going to
straighten the spare leg out behind
you you could argue this is more of a
straight legged deadlift or maybe call
it an ant ior reach which is probably
the better and more accurate term but
either way the aim is to get you hinging
at the hips properly which is important
because we don't have any other hip
hinges in this workout and to help you
keep your hips
stable focus on keeping the back foot
pointing downwards towards the ground as
you raise it up you'll be surprised at
how this drifts for most people I
clearly have some hip issues to work
through and it's an ongoing process for
me look at that back foot it's appalling
disgusting this is functional training
digging into the movement issues and
setbacks that hold back your performance
and dealing with
them and often fixing one issue can
uncover several more you can find that a
tightness in your hip for example is
expressed in your back in your gate
causing knee pain or back pain it's an
ongoing NeverEnding process isn't that
fun this will compound the benefits of
The 100 UPS as well to really improve
your gate it also gives us a little
glute and hamstring training although
not a
lot it is very good for hamstring
Mobility
though the next activation exercise is
the body weight reverse fly also called
an elbow press you don't need a long
rest between these two exercises maybe
30 seconds to a minute and we're going
to do these ones for two sets of eight
or
rp6 that means perceived rate of
exertion six or giving it a six out of
10 effort again we're trying to get the
body to move correctly here this time by
activating the rids and re delts to help
bring the shoulders back into a better
position we've got a lot of horizontal
pushing in this workout and we don't
have a pull-up bar so we need to do
something for that horizontal
pull Li flat on the ground and then
bring the elbows back to drive the Torso
upwards focus on the shoulders bringing
the scapula back and pinching them
together as you push yourself up what's
important here is to recognize that
different exercises in this workout have
different functions this is one thing
that sets functional training apart so
the obvious criticism that I can
anticipate some people making here is
that you won't build big traps or big
lats through this movement it's a short
range of motion the resistance isn't
that high but that's not the point we'll
be building strength and muscle soon
enough this is about activating the
shoulder blades seeing as many people
don't even know how to do that and
teaching ourselves better resting
posture as a result this is training the
neural Pathways and treating strength
like a skill same for anterior
reaches we're now moving on to a lat
exercise for zero equipment the body
weight pullover for two sets of RP
8 it's the first example of how we're
going to get a little creative with
what's available to us so here you're
going to keep your body rigid and rest
on your knees again place both hands on
the sofa with your arms stretched out
overhead straight you should look like
you're going to do a jackal Lane
push-up now you're going to push down
into the saf with your hands in order to
raise up your upper body this is not a
body weight tricep push down so we're
not bending the elbows it's fine to have
them bend a little but you want to put
that emphasis on the lats the aim is to
pull the arm straight down from the lats
which will drive your body upwards at
the same
time
[Music]
it's a slightly awkward one and the
range of motion isn't great but it will
certainly do better than nothing and
again it comes down to your own ability
to feel the exercise working the target
muscles and to utilize that mind muscle
connection so the responsibility here is
on you to feel as though you're training
the
[Music]
lats okay hey enough messing around now
it's time for some serious work two
times one-armed push-ups with a good 1
to 3 minute rest between sets
rp8 again I'm going to be cutting out
the rest seeing as it would make for a
very long and boring video just watching
me sit there do nothing you can just
pause the video for that necessary
amount of
time for me RP 8 is going to mean two
sets of six I'm going to do about 10
maximum on a good day so two sets of six
is plenty challenging this is building
serious PEC shoulder and tricep strength
it's also a huge Core workout as you'll
need to stabilize your midsection to be
able to transer the strength into the
ground the best part is its anti-
rotation that means you're combating
gravity as it attempts to twist your
unsupported side down to the ground
we're building more strength in the
rotational plane then and this is some
of the most functional strength strength
there is whether you're running pushing
pulling throwing or punching it's also
something that many of us Overlook in
our regular training to do the perfect
one-armed push-up you're going to spread
your legs but not too wide which makes
it easier the closer together you can
keeping them the better but you'll be
hard push to keep them directly next to
each other now place your hand in the
middle lower yourself with control and
then push yourself back up once your
nose touches or nearly touches the floor
push all the way through so that you're
extending your arm and protracting your
scapula at the top you might even hear
your back crack which is a great feeling
if you can't do a one-armed push-up you
can do regular push-ups better yet Place
one hand on a raised object and then
move more of your weight to the other
hand you can this way assist yourself
and get a nice deep stretch for the peex
which is a great
stimulus now if you thought that was
enough for your pecs and shoulders
you've got another thing coming now
we're heading over to the stairs to do a
variation of a pike push-up that I think
I invented tell me if you've seen this
anywhere
before two sets of RP 8 and we're going
to rest here for about a minute to 2
minutes anyway the idea as you can see
is to perform a pike push-up but using
the stairs to get yourself into position
so your feet on higher steps than your
hands it's going to be a little bit more
diagonal than your usual Pike push-up
this way where it really comes into its
own is in the way it allows to go into a
really deep deficit you can lower
yourself well past the floor and then
push yourself back up so you're going to
go down diagonally your chins is going
to go past your hands and then keep
going deeper and then you're going to
push yourself up from there I hope it
goes without saying that you should do
this so that your hands are on the
bottom step the only reason I'm not
doing that is that I can't get a good
camera angle that way be sensible and
stop before you're at risk of dropping
off injuring yourself this should be a
nice controlled movement nice and slow
watching this back I can see that I'm a
little
uneven I think that's due to my hand
placement like I think one of my arms is
more diagonal but I do also have one
stronger trap on my left side so I'll be
keeping an eye on
this anyways you do this uh but do it
better please
if the movement is too hard or you don't
have stairs then of course you can use a
sofa to do regular Pike push-ups or you
can do the easier Pike push-up variation
on the
ground now we're moving straight on over
to another challenging pushing movement
these being Pudo planch push-ups for
another two times pr8 with a longer 2 to
3 minute rest this time whatever it
takes for you to be fully recovered so
that you can complete the same number on
the second set to perform a pseudo
planch push-up you're going to get into
push-up position with your hands lower
down your body and Palms Twisted so that
your fingers Point either outwards or
back behind you keeping your upper body
pushed forwards over your shoulders push
up at the top of the movement and make
sure to lock the elbows all the way out
a good cue here is to drill your palms
into the ground by turning them further
outwards until the pit of your elbow
opens out completely this is actually a
movement used in calisthenics to build
straight arm strength the aim is to
strengthen the elbows and the scapula
building up to the planch I'm not that
great at this move so I'm not leaning
all that much furthermore we've just
done a whole bunch for the shoulders so
why are we doing it why is it here in
the program well one reason is that it
can actually build big biceps and
resilient elbows this is not just an
isometric hold for the biceps it's also
placing great strain on the biceps
tendons gymnasts have huge biceps partly
because of all the straight arm training
that they do
just go very careful with this one again
build up to it slowly it's intense if
you're not used to this kind of training
simply turning your hands just a little
outwards will do fine if you're
struggling or even just doing tricep
push-ups to begin with okay now onto
more legs so the first exercise we're
going to do here is the pseudo shrimp
squat I mean that's not an official
title but I don't know what else to call
it it's effectively between a shrimp
Squat and a kickstand
squat so a kickstand squat is a squat
performed so that you essentially squat
on one leg resting the free leg though
behind you with your toes on the ground
to offer some balance and support it's
also though going to help with the
actual movement a little bit inevitably
this is the easier progression for this
exercise so if you can't do these pseudo
shrimp squats then this is where you're
going to start we're doing the same
thing here but we're going to raise the
support leg so that it only comes into
contact with the ground at the bottom of
the squat Al it's only very lightly
touching the ground until the bottom of
the squat it's there just to add balance
to allow you to get into a more upright
posture so that you can drive through
the heel and really involve the glutes
in the movement while I can do a shrimp
squat it's not very elegant and I
wouldn't want to pump out reps this way
we're getting more support so that we
can do 10 reps with some decent
stability and we can focus on building
that ankle Mobility that single leg
strength and that glute and hamstring
strength again your job is to focus on
driving the heel and to make sure you're
engaging the target
muscles you can also do elevated pistol
squats on your stairs with your heel on
a book but I wanted to show some variety
and we did pistol squats last
time
the big reason I've chosen the pseudo
shrimp squat here is that it offers us a
bit more challenge than a typical air
squat for example air squats are great
but they don't do enough to really build
power or strength jump squats are better
but even those are limited when it comes
to hypertrophy they're great for
building explosiveness but there isn't
much mechanical tension muscle damage or
cross bridging to allow for growth with
that said you can get a bit of a pump
this way especially if you then drop set
to regular air squats taking your weight
on one leg though is a good way to do
some real work and on top of that it's
also going to build that symmetry
between your legs and help you do better
balance on one leg these points are
important for performance for obvious
reasons while perfect symmetry between
legs is off the table that's just not
something that exists for anyone we do
want to close that Gap as much as
possible if you're outputting slightly
less force on one leg when running this
compound over a long
distance so how are you I'm good it's
been my kids' birthdays just weeks
before Christmas so we've been very busy
and I haven't had much time for
unwinding in the evenings but when I do
get a moment I've been really enjoying
Sonic Dream Team on the iPad and I've
been playing Duke Nukem on the evercade
specifically I've been really enjoying
playing the original Juke Nukem 1 and
two which have been completely
remastered in a widescreen format and
with smooth 60fps scrolling they're
brilliant and it's like reliving my
childhood let me know in the comments if
any of you know on an evercade is and if
any of you played the original jke nuks
before jke Nukem
3D next up for the legs are squats
I didn't come up with the name this
targets the quads in a big way as well
as strengthening the knees that said
they're also very tough on on the knees
so don't do these if you have existing
issues instead find an easy regression
likewise if you lack the strength for
now then find an easier
regression that easier aggression is the
Hindu squat where you simply squat on
your toes you can do this with a partial
range of motion too if it's too
difficult I'm doing squats with my
hands near the sofa this is just to
support me as I get closer to the ground
giving me the stability I want in order
to be able to build some strength in
hypertrophy remember stability is
necessary for making strength
gains I said if you're more interested
in the balance gains you can try and
ignore the support as much as possible
it becomes quite a cool party trick once
you can do it without focus on driving
your knees forwards towards the
ground so the squat is in here
because once again it say a
significantly challenging movement even
if you're training only with body weight
it isolates the quads really nicely it
also is great to have a knees over toes
movement like this in here we've all
seen what they can do thanks to Ben
Patrick so if you can build up to
squats they're going to give you both
athetics and a better running speed and
jump height perfect for functional
training I would have loved to have
included Nordic curls as well but it's
pretty hard to do that in most homes as
you need something just the right height
to pin your legs
under
okay one last exercise left but it's a
doozy we're going to finish on two
rounds of burpees as a cardio
finisher this will Elevate the heart
rate and get us some of the many
benefits of high-intensity interval
training we're doing two rounds of 15
reps with a good 2 to 3 minute break in
between you should find that's plenty
we're not doing this like they do in the
military though they will stop between
each rep and pause before continuing to
the next one rather we're treating this
as one continuous movement perform the
push-up jump up tap your knees then as
you hit the ground immediately sprawl
into the push-up you're barely tapping
the ground with your toes this method
removes that very short break and means
the heart needs to work over time in
order to get the blood flowing from the
legs to the upper body and back again
you'll find yourself panting and heart
pounding very quickly I also like this
move as it's a full body exercise that
ties together the upper and lower body
we have a bit of a tendency to train the
upper and lower body like two separate
entities and this can result in a kind
of Disconnect making it harder for us to
generate power from the legs and drive
through the
arms here we're going directly from the
feet to the arms and back again the
Burpee also trains the whole body you
train the pecs shoulders and triceps
from the push-up the core from
maintaining a straight body and the legs
from the squat jump you'll even get a
little bit of lat work as you pull your
legs up towards your hands it's very
minor but given how tricky it is to hit
the laps without equipment it's still a
bonus this is a very high impact
exercise when performed this way however
and it will place a fair amount of
strain on the joints especially the
ankles knees and lower back I don't
recommend this for anyone who is
currently struggling with joint pain or
who isn't somewhat athletic other solid
options include High repetition push-ups
or just jump squats you can also perform
a burpee without the jump using either a
squat or just standing up scale this to
your level and take it slowly as always
to finish you're just going to walk on
the spot for two to five minutes until
your heart rate calms back down the aim
is to get the blood flowing back where
you want it so you don't feel dizzy or
sick again you don't need me to show you
how to walk on the spot for 2 minutes so
this is a good point to break that said
do try and concentrate on lifting those
knees up high and keeping those hips
level if you want to see an entire
training plan that goes into far more
depth there can be scales to any level
with various different types of
equipment then check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 that comes with over 2
hours of footage and an 80 plus page
ebook it's designed to make you faster
stronger more mobile even mentally
sharper all at once so you don't have to
choose Link in the description down
below either way thank you so much for
watching guys and I'll see you next time
bye for
now this video was sponsored by
Squarespace
Squarespace is a website building
platform that's ideal for hobbyists all
the way up to massive corporations it
makes the process of getting started
extremely quick and easy while still
offering all of the top level features
you might need to get started you just
need to choose a template that you like
and then customize it to meet your needs
and preferences customization is an
extremely simple drag and drop process
the end result will be something that's
completely personalized while looking
modern and highly professional this
whole process takes minutes and from
there you'll be ready to start posting
content and sharing it with the world
thanks to the in-depth formatting and
editing options create beautiful content
to post or schedule it to post later you
also get seamless social media
integration to share your work with a
wider audience or to publish your social
posts directly to your site there's a
fully featured commenting system too so
that you can build your own Community
right on your site with threaded
comments replies and likes other
features include gated members only
content e-commerce tools analytics and
much more and if you want to take this
further you can install one of the
countless plugins for example you can
add Inventory management global Shipping
and more to your e-commerce solution
Squarespace makes it simple for anyone
to create an online presence something
that is absolutely crucial in the
digital economy head to squarespace.com
to find out more or go to
squarespace.com bioner for 10% off your
first domain or website thanks again to
Squarespace thanks to you guys and bye
for now